ein turm von schnapsflaschen après ski
auch zu corona zeigen in sölden feiern
sie nur am tisch oder maske und mit
größeren tisch abständen das ist
regelkonform das virus feier trotzdem
mit
das wissen sie wohl auf es will keiner
mit mir darüber reden
tirol wird wieder gebucht und tirol ist
wieder hotspot vor allem jüngere stecken
sich hier an
[Musik]
doch diesen pisten können manche nicht
widerstehen
man muss mindestens zwei gläsern und
maske tragen wo abstände und möglich
sind auch traut wer in sölden diese
preise zahlt denn nimmt auch das sind
kaum
spaß am skifahren überwiegt einfach
deswegen klage soll ich kann sehr
angenehm die letzten tagen was ein
bisschen kälter oben auf dem gletscher
man hat vielleicht noch einen schutz
fürs gesicht also ich habe da kein
problem mit doch corona ist ein problem
für wirte eine der zwei hütten auf der
camper ist im notbetrieb personal in
corona quarantäne umso mehr ist es auf
der anderen wie früher voll und viel zu
tun wird roland grüner packt mit an
es fehlen saison weiter überall erzählt
er mehr noch als gäste
die aber schätzen nähere corona hat so
seine vorteile
irgendwie ist eigentlich auch ganz cool
weil nicht so viel los ist kommen so
schnell an die theke rat muss ich so
lange anstehen steht niemand an den
liften die pisten sind frei diese saison
ist sehr entschleunigt entspannt die
leute sind froh dass sie wirklich daran
teilnehmen dürfen an diesem schönen
winter einmal weniger remmidemmi schätzt
auch grüner und langfristig ist die
pandemie ja irgendwann vorbei meint er
andere probleme sind hartnäckig
man sieht ja wir haben nicht viel schnee
aber man hilft sich natürlich mit
kunstschnee ob das
vernünftig oder nicht ist es geht nicht
mehr ohne die skifahrer kommen langsam
wieder dem schnee muss nachgeholfen
werden um die 70 prozent der pisten
österreichs werden geschneit das ist
teuer wenn dann auch noch gäste fehlen
treibt das manche skiorte an den rand
des ruins
[Musik]
lackenhof zum beispiel die letzte
wintersaison fiel komplett aus dieses
jahr ist besser aber nicht genug
der ort galt immer als schneesicher
nun reicht er am grossen ötscher nur für
wenige könne naturschnee genügt nicht
mehr der lift steht die eigner
entschieden nun es ist lacken rufs
letzte saison
ein schock für franz her er hatte
kürzlich rund eine million in seinen
skiverleih und in eine topmoderne
schleifmaschine gesteckt
als die meldung über den center lief
waren wir komplett das zuerst gar nicht
glauben und im hinblick auf unsere
investitionen der letzten jahre war das
der katastrophe das land übernimmt nun
die lifte für zwei jahre eine
galgenfrist sagt bürgermeisterin renate
rückwärts um ideen zu entwickeln ohne
millioneninvestitionen ging es aber
nicht meinen sie und wintertourismus
überleben nur so dass der klimawandel
jetzt schon spürbar ist es logisch dass
wir auch schneekanonen brauchen ist auch
realistisch gesehen das ist einfach so
ja es müssten die pisten präpariert sein
die besteigen muss funktionieren dann
hat man eine chance zum überleben
es geht an das zeigt ein ort der gut
lachen hat in der pandemie
st corona am wechsel erlebt im letzten
jahr einen besucherrekord besonders
familien kann
sie haben sich neu erfunden erzählt karl
morgen besser und dabei sogar
sessellifte abgebaut sie beschneiden nur
wenig und der einzige schlepplift wird
im sommer umgerüstet firma becker wir
wollten unseren
schlepplift auch als bei aktiv nutzen
haben sogar diesen neuen schlepplift
genau deswegen gebaut um den ganzjährig
betreiben zu können wenn sie gegen den
klimawandel angeschnallt hätten wären 15
millionen euro nötig gewesen erzählt er
nun haben sie zwölf investiert in eine
neue sommerrodelbahn in kinder
wanderwege in mountainbike und skitouren
trails und das lockte übers jahr mehr
besucher denn je die pandemie befördert
nach urlaub in der region und zeigte so
die neuorientierung war richtig wir
haben aber 250.000 ankünfte und das
hätte wahrscheinlich die herkömmliche
vitalisierung nicht gebracht dass wir
mit weniger investment deutliche
steigerung der erwarteten besucherzahlen
geschafft sölden rechnet in ganz anderen
dimensionen über zwei millionen
übernachtungen waren es vor corona da
will ich wieder hin man muss den gästen
immer wieder neues und mehr bieten meint
der seilbahn chef gerade auch mit der
klimawandel prognose er plädiert deshalb
für eine verbindung zum nachbar
skigebiet naja sieben police deswegen
weil sie eben in der höhe liegt weil es
gletscher sind das heißt
schneesicherheit wenn diese prognosen
eintreffen das schiff von über 2000 mit
der stadt findet das natürlich auch
genau hinein passt also es ist auf die
zukunft sehr ausgerichtet
es ist ein umstrittenes projekt dieser
unberührte gletscher schmilzt ohnehin
über ihn und weitere soll die verbindung
laufen erzählt naturschützer benjamin
stern dafür müsste diese spitze weg für
eine bergstation ein tunnel gebaut lifte
schneekanonen speichert
so ein projekt sei nicht mehr zeitgemäß
meint erst recht nicht nach gronau die
bevölkerung ist noch sensibler geworden
was derartige eingriffe in die natur
anbelangt und dadurch die ganze corona
situation ist auch klar wie finanziell
nicht einfacher geworden solche mega
projekte zu stemmen im sommer fällt die
entscheidung über die erweiterung nach
einer weiteren corona saison sicher ist
das virus beschleunigt veränderungen die
der klimawandel längst erfordert